[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining
us on I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I'm Emily Fortuna.
Over the next three days, we'll
be live streaming everything
I/O, from keynotes
and expert talks
to a first look at our developer
products and how they work.
EMILY FORTUNA: Keep it locked
to I/O Live for exclusive
interviews,
inspirational stories,
and festival highlights--
all at g.co/io/live.
And don't be shy.
We want to hear from you.
Join the conversation
using #io19.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Coming up at 12:45
PM-- the developer keynote.
But first, our
CEO, Sundar Pichai,
kicks things off with
the Google Keynote.
Stick around
afterwards, because we
have special guests
joining us to break down
all the major announcements.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What do you say?
Should we get the
festival started?
EMILY FORTUNA: Let's do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome,
everyone, to I/O 2019.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's finally here.
Google I/O 2019 is
officially underway.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining
us on I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I'm Emily Fortuna.
If you can't be here this
week at I/O, don't worry.
We're here for you.
Visit g.co/io/live to watch
and rewatch the keynotes
and sessions, plus all the
exclusive interviews and demos
our team of Googlers will be
bringing you over the next
three days.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We've lined
up several special guests
to help us deep dive into
today's major announcements.
First up, we welcome
Manuel Bronstein,
VP of product management
here at Google,
to talk to us about the next
generation Google Assistant.
Manuel, thanks for joining us.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Thanks
for having me here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
let's go really big picture
for a moment.
When you think about how
the Google Assistant changes
people's everyday lives for the
better, what does it look like?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah, so when
we thought about the product,
we wanted to--
our mission is to be the
best way to get things done.
And when we say best, we
think about seamless, fastest,
easiest way to get things done.
And if you think about
our world, in some ways
it's getting more complex.
Every time you try
to do something,
you need to think about not
only what you want to do,
but the how.
And if we do our
job right and we're
investing to make it happen,
you want to be able to go from,
what do I want to
get done, to getting
it done without having to worry
about the how in many ways.
And our hope is that
that saves you time.
And we all know how
important it is for all of us
to get a little bit more time
to do all the things that we
care about.
So we're very proud
to be investing
in making the
product the best way
to get things done, in many
ways, to give users time back.
EMILY FORTUNA: So the
Assistant is becoming
more and more personalized.
How does that help us as well?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: When people
think about an assistant,
they're thinking
about a product that
is going to learn from them,
that is going to understand
what they're saying.
And in order for the system to
understand what you're saying,
it needs to understand
your world, right?
If I say "Call my
wife," it needs
to know that my wife is
[? Arianna ?] and what number
to call.
If I say "Set an
appointment for my kids,"
it should understand
who my kids are.
So when the system starts
getting to know you--
or it even knows where
is home, where is work--
so that I can
know, hey, when I'm
asking it to give me directions,
I say, "Drive me to work."
It can understand that.
The system becomes more
useful, because you can speak
to it in a more natural way.
You don't have to
think about addresses
or you don't have to
think about commands.
You speak to it the same way
you would speak to a friend,
and then it will understand
what you're trying
to do and help you get it done.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What is
your favorite new feature
that Assistant announced
today, and why?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: It's really
hard to pick a favorite.
The team worked really, really
hard on many of the things
that we announced today.
I think that, when you
think about the promise
of the Assistant being the
best way to get things done--
when it starts
getting really fast.
And what we announced
with the next generation
Assistant, one of the
key things about it--
and we're saying it in
a very proud way, which
is, imagine that it starts
understanding you so fast, so
quickly, that speaking to your
phone is faster than tapping,
or that tapping your phone
is going to feel slow.
That's when you know
that you hit something
that could change
user behavior and get
people to start embedding
themselves into this product.
Because it's actually
becoming very simple, but also
very fast and very
efficient in helping you
get your tasks done.
EMILY FORTUNA: That's great.
So in the past couple
of years, we've
seen Assistant play a
much larger role in homes
and phones, and now in driving.
So can you tell us about
the experience for drivers
and what that's like?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah.
When you think about using your
voice and being hands-free,
actually, the car is a
perfect environment for it.
Hopefully people are
driving, and they're
looking at the road, they're
not looking at their phones,
they're not touching
the screens.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You don't
mean hands-free driving?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
Hands-free driving, no.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Your hand's on
the wheel, not on the phone.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Correct.
So when you can think
about it, actually, the car
is one of the places where
the Assistant can be even more
helpful.
But the car is a
hard environment,
because if your windows are
down, there's a lot of noise,
you may lose connectivity,
and so forth.
But one of the things
that we started
thinking about is let's
start from the user,
and what is that
thing that you're
trying to get done when
you're in your car?
And there are
mainly three things.
You're trying to
navigate from point A
to point B. You want
to get to the place,
hopefully fast and safe.
You also want to make sure
that when you're in the car,
you can get
entertained, so you want
to listen to music
or podcasts or radio.
And then, of course, you
sometimes want to communicate.
You want to make a phone call.
You want to receive a text
message or send a text message.
And think about doing all
these things with your hands
while you're driving.
It's probably not the
right way to do it.
It's not safe.
But when you start doing
each of these scenarios,
like driving from
point A to point B,
communicating, or
listening to media,
and you can control
that with your voice
and it understands exactly
what you're trying to get done,
then the product
becomes very magical,
because it's really solving a
real need and a real problem
in an environment
that needs that help.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Can you talk to us
about how the next generation
of the Google Assistant
will change the way that
people interact with it?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Yeah,
so if you think about--
when you start
forgetting about the how
and you start worrying about
what is it that you want to do,
you start relying on the
product in a very different way.
That's when a behavior
change starts to happen.
So in the first phase
of the Assistant,
it should be very
responsive to you.
It should understand
what you're saying,
and then help you get it done.
As this product starts
learning from you,
it can start getting
more proactive.
So now when I get in my
car, it could flash to me
some missed calls or
voicemails that I have,
so that if I want to return
that call, I'm reminded of that.
Or if it knows that,
in my calendar,
I have an appointment at 7:00
PM and it's 6:00 PM or 6:30
and I haven't left--
and it also knows
the information
about where I'm trying to
go and knows the traffic--
it could actually
send me a notification
and let me know, hey, you're
probably going to be late
if you don't leave now.
And it's very interesting
when the product
starts getting more proactive.
I think that we're
going to see a switch--
I see it a lot with my kids--
that, in the same way
that when the screens
became touch screens
and people felt
that every screen is touchable,
and you see a little kid,
and they see an old
TV, and they try
to touch on the screen and
the screen doesn't work.
I think that people
are going to get
used to talking
to their products
and expecting that the
product will understand
what you're saying in a natural
way and help you get it done.
And I think that we're
going to see that evolution
from basically understanding
your commands, what you want
to do and help you get
it done, to getting
very proactive, personal,
and more helpful,
so anticipating your
needs and the things
that you're trying
to accomplish.
EMILY FORTUNA: So you've got
Assistant on your phone, home,
and now driving.
Where do you see Assistants
going in the future?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
It's a great question.
Look, I think that a personal
assistant needs to be with you.
So, of course, a lot of the work
that the team has been doing
is making sure that the
product is available
where you need it the most.
I don't know necessarily
that it's going
to go to different places.
At the end of the day, we
spend time in our homes,
we spend time at work, we
spend time in our cars,
we spend time with our phones--
maybe too much time
with our phones.
But if the product can
always be with you,
then it can help you fulfill
some of those things.
I think that, in the future,
what I'm hoping it helps--
if you think about
the areas where
people spend time trying
to get things done,
but they wish that--
Think about it.
When you want to
go to a restaurant,
the act of going
to the restaurant
and having a nice
meal is awesome.
Maybe calling to make a
reservation is not that great.
But if the product can start
doing those things for you
and remove that load from you,
it becomes incredibly useful.
So I think that if you think
about more of those tasks
that people are trying to get
done and help you anticipate
it, find that ticket
for an event for you
that you want to go to, making
that appointment for you,
and getting predictive
about those things,
then the product becomes
extremely magical.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Before you leave us,
are there any hints you can
give us to find some Easter
eggs in the Assistant?
MANUEL BRONSTEIN: Sure.
We recently launched a new
voice for the Assistant
with John Legend.
It's pretty cool.
And if you ask, actually, if
you turn the voice to the John
Legend voice over
the Assistant and you
ask it to sing a song for
you or sing "Happy Birthday,"
you want to hear John
Legend singing for you.
And it's [INAUDIBLE]
pretty cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
I'm going to do that.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank
you, Manuel, so much,
for sharing your insight.
MANUEL BRONSTEIN:
So great to be here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, it's
time for us to take a break.
When we return, we'll be talking
about the new Google Pixel 3a
and 3a XL.
We're here in Mountain
View, California,
and you're watching I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Joining us now
is Soniya Jobanputra, a product
manager at Google,
who is here to give us
the 411 on those
sleek new phones.
Hi, Soniya.
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Hi, Emily.
EMILY FORTUNA: So your team
has been amazingly busy
these past few months
getting out this new Pixel
to the lineup.
What inspired you to
create this phone?
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: When we
set out to do Pixel in 2016,
we really set out to
do something different,
to really bring radically
helpful hardware
to our consumers.
And we thought we could
do that by bringing
the power of hardware,
software, and AI together.
And we still believe that.
That's still our mission
with these devices.
But with the benefit
of three years,
we've been able to finally
bring a phone that's
more affordable to more people.
And what we've managed
to do is essentially
improve our capabilities from
a manufacturing standpoint,
a hardware design and software
standpoint, and,
three, we've just
understood our users better
over the last three years.
Starting with the third one,
understanding our users--
by understanding our users,
we can pick which pillars
and which parts
of the product are
most important to our users,
and focus on those areas
to design phones that
give users what they
need in a really optimized way.
On the second two, we
really have, year over year,
improved our manufacturing.
When we started out,
we had other people
building our phones for us.
We are now a full-contract
manufacturer.
We design and build
our own devices,
which means we've
come a tremendous way,
from a manufacturing standpoint.
Finally, on the
engineering side--
just last year, we
ended up acquiring
a huge and talented engineering
team in Taiwan from HTC.
That team has been the
lead on these devices,
and they have brought years
and years of experience--
in conjunction with our Chicago
design team and our Mountain
View design team--
to come together to
build this new Pixel
3a device, the more affordable
Pixel device at $399.
EMILY FORTUNA:
That's super cool.
I am personally very excited
to see a new phone come out
with a headphone jack
and a great camera.
What are your three favorite
features on this new phone?
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Well, let's
talk about that headphone jack.
We debated on this
headphone jack.
But we really felt that
consumers, at this price point,
in this price tier,
really needed flexibility.
And that's what that
headphone jack gives you.
We still support digital audio,
and it is the ultimate way
to consume your audio.
You can either use our
USB adapter on the bottom
or you can use
Bluetooth headphones,
and digital audio is incredible.
But a lot of people
have headphones,
and we didn't need to create
any more e-waste in the world.
So we've decided to put a 3.5mm
headset jack in so that people
could use the accessories that
they already had available
to them.
Now, my top three.
Let's start with the
camera, because I
think that's everybody's
top for Pixel in general.
And Pixel 3a is incredible.
It shares the same
camera experiences
that you get on your Pixel
3 device, minus group selfie
mode.
But in general, you get
all the great stuff,
starting with Night
Sight, which lets you take
incredible images in low light.
My favorite is taking
pictures of my kids
when they're sleeping,
because they sleep
in the most awkward positions.
But you would be surprised
at the detail you can get.
You can catch their bedspread,
their little stuffies--
and that's without turning
any lights on in the room.
It is truly incredible.
On top of Night Sight, of
course you get portrait mode,
so you can take those
incredible selfies,
with that bokeh effect,
with that beautiful blurred
background.
And we have a depth
editor, so you
can change and
adjust that just to
how you want to
see that picture.
We also have Photobooth.
Again, I'll say, savior,
when you have kids.
You just turn on the
Photobooth and it
captures the picture when
they're both facing the camera
and smiling.
That is a rare split-second
event anywhere,
and Photobooth captures
it every single time.
And that's also available
on the Pixel 3a.
So by far, the most incredible
thing on this device
is this camera.
It's amazing.
And finally, it has
unlimited storage,
just like our Pixel 3 devices
with high-quality [INAUDIBLE]..
My second favorite has
to be Google Assistant.
Google Assistant is awesome.
It saves time and
effort all day long.
You just have to
talk to the phone
to set reminders,
get directions--
it's super quick and easy.
And when you're
on the go, that's
what you need-- something that's
quick and easy and reliable.
Finally, it also
has call screen.
I don't know about you, but
I get a lot of spam calls.
Call screen is a savior.
And with the power of Google
Assistant and call screen,
I only pick up calls that
matter now, which is amazing.
And the bonus-- you get to
waste a little bit of time,
of that spammer's
time, as they try
to call you and have to deal
with your little automated
message.
So I really appreciate
call screen.
And then my final one
has to be battery life.
We heard this loud and
clear from our research,
that battery life is an issue.
And we all feel this,
this anxiety of,
like, oh no, I have 20%, am I
going to get through the day?
We wanted to eliminate
battery anxiety,
and I think we've done a
fabulous job on these devices.
One, we beefed up the batteries.
So they're just bigger.
On top of that, these both
support Adaptive Battery,
which we introduced on our
Pixel devices earlier this year.
And that just makes the
battery a little bit smarter
around how it's using
the power, extending it.
And so these devices,
both get over--
sorry, up to--
30 hours of battery
life on a full charge.
On top of that, we put a
fast charger in the box.
That's an 18-watt
charger in the box.
You can charge this
bad boy for 15 minutes
and get seven hours
of battery life.
While you're getting ready to
get out the door, charge it,
and you have the whole
night available to you.
It's pretty fantastic.
So those would have
to be my top three.
EMILY FORTUNA: That is
quite an impressive list.
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Thanks.
EMILY FORTUNA: I'd be curious
to learn a little bit more
about the camera itself.
Can you tell me some
more of the specifics
on how it's able to create
all these cool effects?
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA:
Yeah, absolutely.
So it starts with the hardware.
The hardware that we've
picked for these cameras
is not mid-tier.
It is premium hardware.
In fact, the imager on the
rear is the exact same imager
that we use on our
premium devices.
The front imager is also
the same normal field
of view imager that we use
for our premium devices.
So we started with
really great raw images.
From there, our magical
software team took over.
They are phenomenal.
And they really were put
to task on this phone,
because as you may
know, the phone has not
the same type of processing
power as our premium phones.
It has the Snapdragon 670 in
it, versus the 800 series that
sits in our premium phones.
So we've really condensed
their processing power,
and they were still
able to deliver.
They optimized every
last aspect of the camera
features to get them
to work on here.
Each individual feature
was revisited by the team
to not only optimize
the algorithms,
but to optimize the
overall experience to work
on these particular devices.
And they did it.
They did a phenomenal job
of delivering those software
features.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank
you so much, Soniya,
for coming to talk to us
about the Pixel 3a and 3a XL.
SONIYA JOBANPUTRA: Thanks
for having me, Emily.
It's really exciting
to talk about them.
EMILY FORTUNA: If you
would like to learn more,
you should visit
store.google.com.
They're available
online right now.
And it's time for a break.
We'll take a peek into
Google's new Nest Hub Max
to see how your smart home
can become a helpful home.
Stick around.
You're watching I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Joining me now
to talk more about Nest Hub Max
is Prabhu.
Welcome.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Thanks for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So let's
start with a quick overview.
Tell us about the larger
screen, the camera,
and all the cool features
that they activate.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
So Nest Hub Max
is our premium smart
display designed
for the center of
your home, and it
builds on all of the
great experiences
we built with the
Google Nest Hub, which
we launched last year.
So we've got a 10-inch HD
screen for an even bigger screen
for your Google Photos and for
watching YouTube TV and all
of the other experiences there.
It's got premium
stereo sound built in.
And it's also got a
really helpful camera
with all kinds of features and
experiences that it can offer--
everything from video
calling with Google Duo
to peace of mind through the
built-in Nest Cam functionality
that allows you to
keep an eye on what's
happening at home,
to personalization,
through a feature that
we're calling Face Match.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Mm-hmm.
Very cool.
And what's your
favorite feature?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN: So
I personally love the video
calling with Duo, because I've
got a two-and-a-half-year-old
at home, and he loves to call
his grandparents on our Nest
Hub Max at home.
And the auto-framing
feature of our Duo calling
allows him to run
around the room,
and my parents can still
keep track of what's
happening in his busy life.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Let's talk for a
moment about privacy.
There's a huge consumer demand
for privacy and transparency
about our personal
information-- how it's stored
and how it's used.
Now, this seems like
one of those things
that the team was particularly
passionate about and proud of.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Absolutely.
You're absolutely right.
We thought about privacy
from the very beginning
of our process designing
the Nest Hub Max,
and actually, even going
further back, the Nest Hub.
One of the reasons that we
had our first smart display be
one without a
camera is because we
wanted to make it
available as a device
that you would feel
comfortable putting
in any room of your house.
At the same time, we knew
that the camera unlocks
a lot of helpful
functionality, and we
wanted to provide that
option as well for consumers.
And so the way we
thought about designing
the camera was very much with
privacy at the forefront.
We thought about easy
and simple controls
for all of the features,
which are all opt-in features,
and you choose what
you want to use.
And there's simple controls,
like the hardware switch
on the back of the device that
lets you quickly just turn off
the camera and the microphones.
On top of that,
taking a step back
from the individual
products, we, as Google Nest,
have also tried to define a
set of privacy commitments
for the home, which articulates
our point of view on what it
means for us to respect your
privacy in all of the products
that we build.
And those are really
specific, factual commitments
about what you can expect
with your personal data
when you're using our
products in your home.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: One of the
really insightful things
about the keynote
that resonated with me
was that there's a fundamental
difference between a smart home
and a helpful home.
Can you define that difference?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN: Sure.
So smart home
technology is fantastic.
It helps us solve
all kinds of really
interesting and important
problems in our homes
and in our lives.
But one of the challenges
with smart home technology
is it's kind of complicated.
It's not that easy to use.
And so we wanted
to think about how
we can solve that
as we push forward
with our vision for
the helpful home.
And there's a few key
tenants for what we think
the helpful home looks like.
One is that the
products in it should
be easy to use for
everyone in the home.
The second is it
should feel personal.
As you use these
devices, they should
get to know you and be able to
provide an experience that's
tailored to you and your family.
The third is they should
work really well together.
These devices aren't just
operating in a vacuum
individually.
They're helping fill
out your entire home.
And so your whole home should
work together really well.
And then the last is,
of course, the one
we just mentioned,
that it should really
respect your privacy,
and that privacy should
be part of the design
of all of the products
that you bring into your home.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's talk
about design a bit more.
I think designing
for a screen that's
meant to be viewed
up close, far away,
and from different angles-- it
seems like a really difficult
problem.
Can you talk about
your design process
while addressing that challenge?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Absolutely.
So when we started
working on the Google Nest
Hub, the first smart
display that we built,
we were thinking about
that first and foremost.
Because we wanted
this device to feel
like an ambient, glanceable
device, not one that needs your
focused attention for
long periods of time.
And so we designed the user
experience on that device
to be readable from a
variety of distances.
Obviously, the fact
that it's voice
means that it can be used
from both near and far.
Then, when we went
to the Nest Hub Max
and we added a
camera to the device,
the other thing that
we thought about
was, how can the camera help
solve that same problem for you
and your family in the home?
And so an important
decision we made
was to provide a really wide
field of view for the camera.
It's got a 127
degree field of view.
So if you think about all the
experiences that you're using
the camera for,
from video calling,
where it allows you to
move around the room with
auto-framing, to the built-in
Nest Cam functionality,
where you can get a pretty
good view of what's happening
in the room, to the
personalization with Face
Match, where our thinking
was the device should be able
to tell that you're looking at
it when you can see it and when
you would be able to receive
the personalized experience that
it's giving you--
and so all of those
design decisions
helped us to feel
like we're extending
that "whether near
or far, it's great"
experience from the Nest
Hub to the Nest Hub Max.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
OK, one last thing.
During user research, what
was the most fun thing
that you saw someone do
that you didn't expect?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
So one of the things
I love about our
user research is
that we get to see how our
products fit into their homes,
and we get to feel the impact
that we're having on real homes
and real people.
And one small
example of an insight
that we get from that
research is, hey,
where do people put
our devices when
we get them in their homes?
And we learn a lot from, for
example, the other Googlers who
test our products and
help give us feedback
before we ship
them to the public.
And there was one
email thread where
a Googler who was
testing the Nest Hub Max
showed a photo of his living
room, where he had the Nest Hub
Max, which is already
a pretty big screen,
sitting right next to his big
flat-screen TV on the wall.
And that was
obviously not what I
had expected, because I figured
these devices are big enough
that you're going to put this
bigger screen in a room that
doesn't really have
another screen.
But we had a dialogue
with the Googler,
and we realized the value
of checking your assumptions
and learning from
what people do to fit
your products into their home.
So he loved the photo
frame in his living room
and loved that you can see it
from a little farther away,
because it was bigger.
He loved the fact
that it had a clock
that he could look at any time.
He loved that he could control
his TV and his home theater
system by voice
through this device.
And so I think that every
time we actually see
how our products fit into
people's homes, we learn a lot,
and that's one of the most
fun examples of research
that we do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks
for swinging by, Prabhu.
This has been really insightful.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Nest Hub Max will
be available later this
summer in the US, Australia,
and the UK.
And we're going to
take a short break.
Up next, we'll turn our
attention to augmented reality.
You're watching I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Welcome
back to I/O Live.
Here with us now
is Harsh Kharbanda,
product manager on Lens.
Welcome, Harsh.
HARSH KHARBANDA: Hi, Emily.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Harsh, there
were so many AR announcements
at I/O. Let's go a little
deeper with one of them--
Lens and Google Go.
Can you take us back to when you
all were first conceiving it?
What were the problems that
you were trying to solve?
HARSH KHARBANDA: Sure.
So technology's getting
cheaper and more accessible.
Smartphones today can
cost as little as $50.
And while building all our
OCR and document structure
understanding
capabilities in Lens,
we realized that these can
be transformational for users
new to smartphones.
There are two things that
we realized about users
who are new to smartphones.
The first thing is that
the smartphone is likely
their first digital device.
Unlike you and I, they haven't
grown up with desktops.
And so the keyboard itself
is a novel concept for them.
They have to learn how
to express information
needs for the first time
on a 2-inch keyboard,
and typing is just
fundamentally hard.
The second thing we realized was
that these users typically have
lower literacy rates, which
means that they come across
text throughout their lives--
bank forms, ATM notices,
street signs--
text that they want to
understand, but really
have to depend on
others to do so.
But the camera is something
everybody knows how to use.
The selfie has really made
its way around the world.
So we thought, what if we
could build a camera that
could help you
learn, understand,
and read the world around you?
And that's what we did
with Lens and Google Go.
EMILY FORTUNA:
That's super cool.
I foresee myself making use
of Google Go when I travel,
for example.
It's like, if I don't know
the language or the alphabet,
it's like I have my own
personal translator.
Can you tell us
about the first time
you saw someone use Lens
how you had envisioned?
HARSH KHARBANDA: Sure.
So we've been testing
Lens and Google
Go over the past several
months, and we've seen people
use it in several
different instances
throughout their daily lives--
bank forms, ATM notices,
product packages,
medicine labels.
But the point where
we realized we
were making a true impact
in the users' lives
was when we saw a parent
using Lens and Google
Go on their child's
homework, to understand
what the homework
problem was and help them
in their education.
Before that, their
homework was in English.
The parent could not
really help the child.
But in this case, they were
able to take a picture,
translate it into the
language that they understood,
and understand the
problem and be,
really, a part of their
child's education.
And that is something
that's really
humbling and gratifying to see.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Harsh, that
sounds really awesome, and also
fairly complex.
Can you tell us about some
of the technical challenges
that you faced
while building this?
HARSH KHARBANDA: Yeah.
So to be able to
do all of this, we
had to bring the
technology to a phone
that new smartphone users
would be able to afford.
And so we had to bring OCR
to be able to understand
the text that users take a
picture of, machine learning
to translate the text
into the language
that these users speak, TTS
to be able to read it out
in a very naturally
accented form,
and even AR to highlight each
word as it's being read out--
all done on a phone that
cost as little as $50
in an APK footprint
of 100 kilobytes.
And that was a really hard
technical challenge for us.
EMILY FORTUNA: Harsh, thank you
so much for joining us today.
HARSH KHARBANDA:
Thank you, Emily.
EMILY FORTUNA: To learn
more about Lens and Google
Go, visit lens.google.com.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
the developer keynote
is just minutes away.
Join us afterwards for more
interviews with special guests,
plus we'll head
over to our sandbox
area for some awesome demos.
You're watching I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Welcome
back to I/O Live.
We're excited to have
Daniel Galpin here
to tell us about Android News
from the developer keynote.
Hey, Daniel.
DANIEL GALPIN: Hi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, Dan.
So responsibility to our
users was the first core part
of the Android
Developer keynote.
Now, how does this
relate to developers?
DANIEL GALPIN:
Well, users trusting
the platform is inherently
important to developers.
Downloading an app
is something we all
want users to feel
comfortable doing.
And that's why we've
given users more control
over their identity, [INAUDIBLE]
apps run in the background,
and about how app share
storage with each other.
Now, these platform
changes ultimately
will require some
apps to make changes
when they target [? queue ?]
but it's important for everyone
that we get this right.
EMILY FORTUNA: Tell me more
about how the Android Studio
team focused on
quality improvements
for their latest release.
DANIEL GALPIN: Well, we're
always listening to developers.
And while new IDE
features are great,
they don't mean
anything if your coding
is interrupted with the crashes
and performance problems.
So the team has fixed over
400 high-priority bugs
and made existing
features work better.
For example, we've
rewritten Instant Run
from the ground up with
a more solid foundation,
renaming it Apply Changes.
And developers can try all of
this today in the 3.5 Beta.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, what's
the latest with Google Play?
DANIEL GALPIN: Well, it's
all about app bundles.
And they make sure
that the devices get
just the parts of
the APK they need,
which has turned into an
average of 20% smaller
downloads for users.
We've also recently launched the
1.0 release of dynamic feature
modules, which allows
apps to have even smaller
initial downloads
by choosing which
parts to download at launch.
And speaking of distribution,
we launched inline app updates
today, which provides
a standard way
to prompt users to update
their app when a new version is
available on Play.
EMILY FORTUNA: So what's about
the updates to Android Jetpack?
DANIEL GALPIN: Well,
Android Jetpack
is another way
we've been investing
in developer productivity.
And CameraX is a huge step
forward in making it easier
for Android apps to
access the camera
and get consistent
behavior across devices.
We've also continued to
improve Jetpack's architecture
components, having recently
released WorkManager
and the Navigation
Controller into stable,
adding enhanced Rx
Java support for Room,
adding Kotlin [INAUDIBLE]
support to Room lifecycle
and live data, and adding save
state support to ViewModel.
And we're also continuing
to expand the architecture
components, and
Jetpack in general,
to tackle new pain points,
including the new benchmarking
library.
Also the early source for a new
Kotlin-first, reactive UI tool
kit we're developing in
the open, Jetpack Compose,
is now available.
So check it out and
give us feedback.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Android development
is becoming Kotlin-first.
Why is Kotlin-first important?
DANIEL GALPIN: Well,
the world has spoken.
Kotlin is wildly popular.
Over 50% of pro-Android
developers are using it,
and it means much less code
to type, test, and maintain.
Now, of course, we're continuing
to invest in C++ and Java
programming language.
And all three choices
remain great options
for Android development.
That being said, I'm
excited to see the reaction
to our new free Udacity
course developing
Android apps in Kotlin.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks
for stopping by, Daniel.
That was a lot of really
great information,
and we really appreciate it.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Thank you, Daniel.
DANIEL GALPIN:
Thank you, Timothy.
Thank you, Emily, and I
appreciate talking to you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
time to step away
for some more sessions.
Be sure to join the
conversation at #io19.
You're watching I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: Welcome
back to I/O Live.
Joining us now is Yossi
Matias, vice president
of engineering at Google and
the head of the Google R&D
Center in Israel.
Thanks for being here, Yossi.
YOSSI MATIAS: Thank you
very much for inviting me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Yossi, you're involved
with AI for Social
Good, and you've
worked on an impressive number
of projects surrounding that.
How did you get into that area?
How did it start up here?
YOSSI MATIAS: So in a way, we
were working on Social Good
from the early days in Google.
It's part of the
DNA of the company
to try and use technology to
solve problems for people.
And obviously, in the last
couple of years, where AI
is getting a lot of--
we became an AI-first company.
And AI had all
these advancements.
So suddenly, we started looking
into how to leverage on AI,
how to use it to solve those
problems, societal problems,
that can help out people
in a profound way.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
specifically, you've
worked on flood prediction.
And in my experience,
predicting the future
is not a task best
left to mere mortals.
So I'm curious if you could tell
us how you got started on that
and how it actually works.
YOSSI MATIAS: Sure, yeah.
There's an old saying that
prediction is hard, especially
about the future.
So I've been
leading a team which
is working on crisis response,
where the mission of the team
is to develop technologies to
help people during crisis--
natural disasters
and other crises--
by providing the right
information to people.
And in fact, my
involvement in that
going back eight and a half
years where, as a user,
I had the experience--
we had a devastating
fire in Israel.
And it was near our office,
in our Haifa office.
We have offices in
Tel Aviv and Haifa.
I was visiting that day.
And I didn't know what
I should be doing.
I saw this huge smoke.
I didn't find any
information on the internet.
And this was actually
the first time
that I experienced the
need for information,
and it was not until I actually
called the mayor's office
that I got the phone number
of actionable information.
And in fact, at that
time, I asked my team
to see how to make
that information
available to everybody.
And within a few hours, anybody
searching for "fire in Israel"
could get that information.
So this was the
first example where
we gave actionable
information to people.
Now, fast forward--
now we integrated
into Search something
we call SOS alerts,
which essentially provides
information about major crises
when they happen.
And one thing we discovered
is that we can only
give information which we have,
but one of the most devastating
natural disaster is our floods.
They impact up to 250
million people per year,
and there are thousands of
fatalities because of them.
And in many cases, we don't have
information about where floods
exactly is going to occur.
So we knew this is
an important problem,
but it wasn't clear
whether we can actually
do anything about it.
There was an engineer
that just joined,
and he said he wants to
work on a project that
could help save lives.
And I asked him, well, why don't
you spend part of your time
seeing how much we can advance
using AI and other technologies
in order to help out
with flood forecasting?
And within a few months,
he made enough progress
that he actually built
a team around it.
And in less than a
year, actually, it
was ready as a pilot in
the Patna area in India.
And that's how, actually,
the flood forecasting effort
came to life.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And when you first
started looking at that problem,
did you think it was solvable?
YOSSI MATIAS: So actually, when
I had a discussion with him,
I told him that I'm
not sure if we're
going to be able to solve it,
because in order to really--
and we were focusing on, really,
what we call riverine floods.
These are floods where the river
starts rising because of water.
Then, you know, then there's
likely going to be some floods.
But the important
information to know
is exactly where the
floods is going to occur,
because it's only then that
people will take action.
It's only then that
people would evacuate,
or it's only then
where government
can take action and
evacuate the right people
from the right places.
Now, in order to get these
accurate predictions,
there's a lot going on.
You need to have relatively
fresh information about where
the water already is in order
to make the predictions.
We are leveraging on the fact
that we have a better elevation
models for many more
places around the world,
and that elevation
model itself is computed
with a lot of some of the
advanced technologies-- machine
learning, aerial imagery, and
the other data that we have.
It's using a lot of
computational power
to do hydraulic simulations,
and complimented also
with machine
learning techniques,
and it's using
information that we're
getting through a partnership
with the Indian government,
where they're actually measuring
the water level in quite
a few rivers and
trying to actually make
sense of what's going on there.
So this is really
a true partnership
with the Indian
government on that.
And as it turns out, we could
actually get into prediction
a few hours before the floods
actually get to the level
that it did of over 90%
accuracy, which was actually
quite impactful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
that's hugely impactful.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
How were you able to connect
with the Indian government
and get these people
involved in the project?
YOSSI MATIAS: You
know, the beauty
is that once we started
working on that,
there's a lot of
interest to collaborate.
And I would say that on many
of the societal problems,
the notion of collaboration
between companies
and communities and
entrepreneurs and governments--
I think this is one of the areas
that we need to see more of.
Because these are big
problems, and we do
need to have this
kind of community
effort and global effort in
order to really tackle them.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
EMILY FORTUNA: Thank
you so much, Yossi.
And thank you for helping
create this environment
to be able to make
these projects possible.
YOSSI MATIAS: Well,
it's a privilege
to be able to have this
kind of environment
and to work with people who care
about how to use technologies
to solve big problems.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, let's
now head over to the sandbox
to see some awesome demos.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So here,
I have Bhavin and Greg
from the Android
team who are going
to show us more about what's up
with 5G here at Google I/O. So
what's new here, and what
are we showing today?
BHAVIN ROKAD: So at I/O, we want
to demonstrate to developers
how Android is leading the
way when it comes to 5G
and what it means for them.
In 2019, 5G is launching with
over 20 carriers worldwide,
and on more than a
dozen Android OEMs.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: OK, cool.
So there are going to be
all these devices out there.
So what APIs have we now added
to Android to allow developers
to use this kind of capability?
GREG LEON: Yeah,
so we've extended
our connectivity manager
API to be 5G-aware,
so that you'll know when you
have an amazing 5G connection
from a bandwidth perspective.
Additionally, we've also added
the meteredness component
to the API, so that you'll know
when that connection is metered
or unmetered so, you can
do interesting things
over the 5G connection.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: All
right, so metered
means you're paying for it
per gigabyte or something
like that.
GREG LEON: That's right, yeah.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: So that
would be a great opportunity
to download movies
before a flight,
or when you're going away
with there's no connectivity?
GREG LEON: That's right, yeah.
So you can do all of these
great downloads of content
before you jump on a
plane, for example.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
All right, nice.
So from what I understand,
5G is a lot faster
than previous phone
networks, and it
sounds like it has the ability
to do really fast downloads.
So you have a phone
there that is 5G-aware.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yeah,
so let's take a look.
To help demonstrate
5G at I/O, we've
actually set up three
live networks here at I/O
on a range of six OEM devices.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Oh, wow.
So that's something people
don't get to see every day.
Here at Google I/O, we actually
have real cell phone company
base stations for our demos.
So let's see what this looks
like on a real 5G phone here.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yep.
So one of the challenges
that many of the AAA app
game developers
might run into is
that file sizes get larger
and larger as we make
games more and more immersive.
For instance, this
game is two gigabytes,
and that file size could
mean the difference
between acquiring a
user or not, especially
if they're on the go.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Those
could take hours.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yes, exactly.
So with 5G, we can see that
the download gets kicked off
relatively quickly,
and we're downloading--
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: 43 megs.
Oh, wow.
BHAVIN ROKAD: 62.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: 62 megs.
BHAVIN ROKAD: 120.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Oh, wow.
So it's going like
60 megs at a time.
Wow.
BHAVIN ROKAD: 200, 300--
so we're cranking right along.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah,
well, that's really quick.
So what technological advances
have they added to 5G in order
to get the speed
achievements that we're
seeing in [? demo here? ?]
GREG LEON: Yeah, so we've
done a few things for 5G.
One is new spectrum
mid-band and high-band,
increase the
robustness of the link
through beamforming
technology and Massive MIMO.
And also, we've
improved latency,
which is really
important for gaming,
through shorter packet sizes
and distributed core network,
which is taking the central core
infrastructure of the carrier
and bringing it closer
and closer to the user.
And that's allowed for
a much better latency,
and that really matters
to things like gaming.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Yeah, that
sounds like it would really
help consumers,
and also developers
who are going to be
[INAUDIBLE] these kind of apps.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Yeah, absolutely.
And you can see we're
ready to play the game.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Oh, wow.
Cool.
So that's all done, so
we're ready to roll.
OK.
Thanks for talking to us today.
Appreciate your time, and I'm
sure everyone's looking forward
to trying this out.
GREG LEON: All right, thank you.
BHAVIN ROKAD: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That'll do it
for day one here at I/O Live,
but we've only
started to scratch
the surface of the festival.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Yes, tomorrow we'll
check out some cool product
demos in the sandbox.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
we'll recap all the I/O
After Dark festivities.
If you're into roller
rinks and arcades,
you're going to want to tune in.
EMILY FORTUNA: Super cool.
The remaining sessions of
the day are about to begin.
Remember to visit g.co/io/live
to check out our videos
on demand.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Have a
great rest of the day.
Emily and I will
see you tomorrow.
EMILY FORTUNA: Bye for now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]